AUDIENCE: One of the
biggest challenges
in the visual
effects industry when
you work a feature
movie, everybody
in the last few months
needs render power.
So in your situation, let's say
you get everybody to go online,
and then everybody
suddenly needs render power
these last two, three months.
What is your capacity?
Where are the limits?
Or is it possible that
end up in a situation
where it's like, oh, sorry.
You have to wait a
week or so before we
can give you render nodes?
JEFF KEMBER: So at this point,
I turn around and tell you
that we have unlimited
compute power.
AUDIENCE: But will you have it?
Because now, you
don't have the market.
Because I can tell from
first-hand experience, most
Edge studios, they go
and rent render nodes.
And I had when I went to the
render node company and said,
what's going on?
Everybody wants render nodes.
What show are you working on?
And we were all
working on 2012 movie,
and we couldn't
get render nodes.
And it got even to the point
where I couldn't buy CPUs
because all the vendors
were like, no, we
have to wait two months.
All the CPUs are sold out.
JEFF KEMBER: I'm actually
with you on that.
I worked on a show
where we were in Sydney.
And we ended up having to
get the avatar render farm
and put in the container and
float it across to Sydney,
and then hook it up at the docks
in order to finish our show.
So I totally
understand the scarcity
of resource in that regard.
What I can say is that Google
buys about 19%, just under 20%,
of the global Intel production.
It's just crazy how
many cores there are.
The fact that we have this
planetary network, and also
the fact that we have data
centers in multiple locations
in the planet, we have customers
who are rendering in Iowa,
for instance, in central
US, who are in Asia
because it's slightly
less expensive for them
to render there.
And once you get past the
whole file system in the cloud
and syncing your
asset issue, you
can render anywhere
on the planet.
So we are much less susceptible
to localization issues
as far as there's a
huge amount of rendering
required in A or B.
Also, because of our
clients are diversified
across a whole
bunch of verticals.
So although the visual
effects industry
is going to have the
summer blockbuster
and the Thanksgiving push
and all of the little bumps,
or commercial divisions are
going to have the Super Bowl,
those are quite small
workloads compared
to the planetary compute
resource that Google has.
So although I can't promise
truly unlimited cores,
if you get in touch with
us a few days in advance,
capacity planning can
move things around
to a significant level.
There's data loads that can
be moved from one data center
to another.
If you need 10,000 cores on
Wednesday and it's Monday,
talk to us, and
concessions can be made.
I will hand the mic
down just in case
if anyone else wants to hold it.
MATT O'CONNOR: The
one other thing
I would add, from a
Google point of view,
is we would relish the
opportunity to try to break us.
As Jeff points out, we have
a lot of cores available.
AUDIENCE: Question back here.
SIMON WISTOW: I was going
to say the other big program
during render pushes is
that everyone's sleeping
under the desk and the office
gets really, really dark
and funky, and everyone smells.
That's the other limiting
factor, lack of swag t-shirts
that you can change into.
AUDIENCE: I guess
one other thing, too,
for production people,
us in the fields,
if we're in the
jungles of Costa Rica
or anywhere that maybe we
might not have connectivity
to the cloud, what
kind of offerings,
or do you guys know of anything,
kind of a queuing system?
Where hey, I can be
with no connectivity,
do my job, almost a script-like,
without being a programmer
myself.
Once I get connectivity,
everything's
going up to the cloud and
computing and everything else.
I don't know if
that makes sense,
but it's one of
the things that we
deal with on a
regular basis where
we don't have connectivity,
like South Africa,
for example, when we've
been there working
and we want to work
with in the cloud.
Is there any kind of queueing
model that is coming up,
I guess, in the
future of offline?
JEFF KEMBER: I'll pick
that up really quickly
and say we don't have a
specific offering for the middle
of Africa on set.
However, if you look at
technologies like the Loon
project, where we
have big hydrogen
balloons flying around the
planet providing connectivity.
And we also have an
aerospace division
that we've announced
that has giant flying
airplanes and other cool
technology like that.
You can Google that
up and find out more.
But the point is the possibility
of providing connectivity
anywhere on the planet
is in the future.
Today, we are partnering
with companies.
I can suggest Iron
Mountain being local here
in Los Angeles, where
you can potentially
take a Hitachi BlueArc
in the back of a truck
and plug it in with 40-gig
pipes and upload to the cloud
and not have to burden
your own system.
So happy to talk
with you further
about possible ideas you have
as far as how to make that go.
But beyond the global wireless
goodness and a pickup truck,
those are kind of our
two options right now.
Anyone else want
to pick that up?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a storage
engineer at Google.
So the cool thing
about Google is
we have a very
large global network
with more interconnection
points than any other network
provider on the planet.
And we actually have
connectivity to South Africa
as well.
That's one of the
peering points.
And so one of the cool things
about the Google Cloud Platform
is that once your network
packet comes from your facility
through some ISP, typically
directly to Google,
then you get a high-speed
first class ticket
straight to our data centers.
So the reason we run our
global fiber backbone
is because we want to
control high traffic runs.
It's a software-defined
network that's heavily
optimized for client traffic.
So there's basically full
utilization with no congestion
for your traffic.
So as soon as you make it to the
Google connection points, then
you go straight to our data
centers and our network.
So that's the best we can offer.
MILO BABIC: One of
the things that we're
doing for our customers
is offering them
an additional piece
of software that
allows them to ingest content
into the cloud environment
and automatically adjust to
the networking conditions.
To give you an example is if
the average video feed runs
at six megabits per second
and your bandwidth drops down
to one megabit per second,
we'll automatically
additionally compress
that, add a little bit
of additional latency
on top of that,
just to make sure that we
can get all the bits in.
We'll reorder the packets
and everything else,
make sure that they do land
inside a cloud environment,
until either better
connectivity becomes available
or there's ability
to peer directly
into the Google network.
AUDIENCE: You guys mentioned
about the MPAA certification
as the second half of 2015.
How realistic is that?
Because a small
studio that would
like to get bigger
projects and count
with a cloud platform for that.
If the studios don't
allow you to use it,
that's a big problem because
basically, we cannot do it.
MATT O'CONNOR: So there's
two pieces to that.
One is right now, we're
waiting on the MPAA.
We're waiting for their revised
best practices document.
I'm pretty confident that
we can meet or exceed
the requirements that
are in that document.
So my challenge becomes, how do
I convey that to the industry?
And so this is a
little bit of what
we'd like to help facilitate
with the industry is,
how do you want to verify this?
Who do you want to trust in
terms of yes, these security
controls at this vendor are
meeting this requirement
in the specification?
Is it going to be a
self-certified process,
or are we going to use the
big five auditing firms?
We'd like to help facilitate
that conversation so
that we can do it in a standard
fashion and it makes sense.
So the realistic timeline on
being able to-- as soon as I
get my hand on that spec, I
can answer it pretty quickly.
I have all the evidence.
And based upon what I
believe is in there,
I think we have good
answers to those questions.
Whether you believe me or
not, that's another thing.
But I've got no reason to
not tell you the truth.
I mean, I want your business.
I don't want to trick you.
So-- no, no, no,
but I mean, it's-
AUDIENCE: My concern
is not just Google.
It's the whole
interaction with the MPAA.
MATT O'CONNOR: Yeah.
So our hope is that the industry
embraces that as a standard
and it works for them.
Short of that, the other
thing that we're doing
is we're also engaged
in conversations
with the major
studios and talking
to them about the unique
requirements they might have
as a different
company, or how we
can work with them to satisfy
answering their questions.
They may have an
independent auditor
that they'd like us to
talk to and work with.
We've had some discussions
along those lines.
They may want to do some
auditing themselves.
We're having some discussions
along those lines.
So we're trying
to navigate that.
And we're trying to
do it as quickly as we
can so that it's not a barrier.
I wish I could tell you, yep,
December 15 we'll be done.
I don't want to make
that commitment to you.
But what I will commit to is
that this is important to us.
And we are watching
it very, very closely.
And we're doing, I
think, everything
that we can do to make sure that
we're making progress there.
I think that's probably the
best answer I could give you.
AUDIENCE: So I'll step in.
I was part of the team that
helped craft that stuff
and hand it off to the MPAA.
So if you want to get
an advanced look at some
of that stuff to be ready
for it when it comes out,
I would look at the CSA, the
Cloud Security Alliance, which
helped craft the
document, and ISE,
which is the lead
auditor for Marvel
and the Disney groups,
which help also drive this.
So those two organizations
would be the best one
to get an advance view.
AUDIENCE: CSA and ISE?
AUDIENCE: Yes, CSA and ISE.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Eric Weaver.
I work with the ETC.
So we help drive some of
those standards and changes.
So.
MODERATOR: Thanks.
Additional questions,
questions, questions?
I think it's time, then.
Please thank all of our
panelists, all of our speakers.
Good job, guys.
[APPLAUSE]